hey Conan O'Brien here these are very  strange times a lot of us are stuck in  our homes and we have to do a lot of  do-it-yourself repair little things  happen here and there and we need to  take care of it ourselves  okay for example I have a problem here  with this bathroom sink as you can see  it's dribbling water has been for a  while and I can't get it to stop so I  got a mat up and take care of this  myself  fortunately I'm pretty handy tool kit  right here  we need handle probably not necessary  but you might need it screwdrivers of  course two different sizes goggles in  case the job gets messy of course you're  going to need adjustable pliers and then  most important of all a sharpie you're  going to need a Sharpie - and  I'm always here to help